so like these work spouses
[Music]
they are so dangerous so so dangerous do
the work spouses
end up like stealing the man ever the
woman vice versa like will they leave
the relationship for them or they just
get like they're just trouble
I mean a lot of times the work spouses
have spouses uh right so if I if if we
are work spouses you have your spouse at
home I have my spouse at home you know
it's it can be that your spouse finds
out about me man I mean leaving my wife
all right and so it gets very very
complicated but uh you don't typically
see work spouses leaving their spouses
and then coming together you don't you
don't typically do you think